- That's a big penis.
- It is a big penis.
- Yeah.
- [Keith] So today the
Try Guys and their dads
are reacting to Try Guys videos.
- [Zach] So we've talked
a little bit about you
and who you are, but now
we thought it'd be fun
to talk about me.
- Talking about you is
something you do very well.
- [Eugene] Why would you
wear this on camera, dad?
- Because I want him to
give me another new one.
- [Ned] What do you not
like it when I do in videos?
The one where we were, like,
wearing giant dick costumes?
- I could've done without that one.
- You have toothpaste stains all over it.
You need to wash it.
- [Keith] What's your favorite
Try Guys video you've seen?
- I like the educational ones.
I guess you could say
they're all educational?
- [Keith] Yeah, I like to think that.
They just don't all educate
you on things you need to know.
- Let's watch some of these videos.
- So the first video is the
Try Guys Labor Pain Simulator.
- [Eugene] So you think it's funny?
- [Eugene's Dad] Yeah.
- You like seeing me in pain?
- Right, right.
- [Ned's Dad] It's tough
to watch Ned in pain.
Zach, nah.
- [Ned] Would you ever
do something like this?
- [Nurse] Okay, show me your taint.
- [Zach's Dad] I see no reason
to do anything like this.
- No, I think it's good
to see someone else,
that's good enough for me.
- [Zach's Dad] Good to know
you're getting paid for it
if nothing else.
- [Ned] Oh I'm screaming hard now.
- Why am I watching this?
This is just stupid.
And you don't even get a baby out of it.
- No.
- I put it near my balls.
- That looks really painful.
Why did you do that?
- Because that's where my vagina would be.
- Oh, I see.
- [Eugene] Aren't you proud of me?
You don't have to answer that.
- Your Try Guys Drag
Performance, great one.
You became a star in this one.
- How do I look?
- Oh, that's you, huh?
- Keith, you're so, so outstanding.
- Sexy.
- You think he looks sexy?
- [Eugene's Dad] Yeah.
He's not.
- Who do you think was the hottest?
- Okay, not Keith.
- Hey, he's gorgeous.
- She's sexy, but she's
also a little dirty.
- You have to be.
- [Zach] Have you ever
tried walking in heels?
- [Zach's Dad] Absolutely not.
- Not even for like funsies?
- Not for... No.
- [Eugene's Dad] She
looks like a nice lady.
- When a drag queen
looks like a real woman,
they call him a fish.
- I'd say he's fishy.
- Who do you think is
the best looking Try Guy?
- Of course Eugene Yang.
- Thank you.
- I would ride the ugliest girl.
Remember how you do nude t-shirts?
- We're gonna move on to the
Try Guys Ancient Olympics.
- Do you think it's bad that
I'm naked so much on camera?
- Not really, no.
You've got a nice body,
so you need to show it.
- Thanks, dad.
- So this was actually
half manure, half dirt,
so we were essentially
rolling around in poop.
- It's better than peat
moss, it'd stick to you.
- I guess it's better than peat moss.
- We spent more hours
pixelating this video
than we've spent editing
anything else we've ever done.
- So like, 40 hours of blurring.
- To see how much is pixelated, you know.
- Is that a dick size reference?
- [Ned] Get some!
- [Ned's Dad] Get some!
- Oh, damn dad.
- [Ned] The thing was,
I really wanted to win.
- [Ned's Dad] I got that.
You've had a history of getting
intense for competition,
but that's what you do
when you're competing.
- That's what you do
- I mean, that's what you do.
- That's what you do.
That's what you do.
- Can you beat Zach and Keith?
- I think so.
- Up next, oh, Try Guys
Halloween Costumes.
- [Ned's Dad] This video is stupid.
- You think Eugene is stupid?
- [Zach's Dad] You look adorable as a bug.
- Thank you.
- Would you wear the bug?
- I'd never give it much thought.
- [Ned] Yeah, yeah.
My dad hates this.
- Have you seen a vagina that big?
- Huge, huge.
- Huge.
- Me as a vagina is...
- One of your iconic moments.
- Sure.
- So Zach was really excited
that his face is the clitoris.
- Oh, that's too high.
- Ohhhh my godddddddd, I am the clitoris.
- [Ned's Dad] We're all proud of you, Ned.
Even you were dressed
up in a penis costume.
That's our Ned.
- [Ned] So I have a history
of not liking giant dicks.
- What does that mean, Ned,
that you have a history
of not liking big dicks?
- You got a black eye from a giant dick?
- Ohhh my godddddd.
- Alright, so this Try
Guys Try Prostate Exams.
- You are a doctor.
Did you particularly like this video?
- I thought it was a
good educational video.
- Do you do that a lot?
Do you have to do that to people?
- A lot, yeah, you have to.
- Can you do it to yourself?
- You have to be very flexible.
- [Keith] So we've been going
to the UCLA Medical Center
for all our medical videos,
and they've gotten to know us real well.
- I'll bet.
- Do you think I'm ever
gonna regret having
a prostate exam on camera?
- No. When you show your kids,
ehhhhh.
- I'm certain that these
videos are affecting change.
If this video helps one
person, it's worth it,
and I'm sure it helped
a lot more than one.
- See, we're getting fingers
up our butts for a reason,
mom.
- Alright, let's swim with sharks.
- [Keith's Dad] Which Try Guy was least
comfortable with this?
- [Keith] We all thought
it was gonna be Zach,
'cause Zach's afraid of fish.
Just like normal fish.
- [Zach's Dad] I have
witnessed it many times.
- [Keith] But Ned, he freaked out.
He had a really tough time.
- [Eugene's Dad] That's
real sharks, right?
- Yeah, they're not fake sharks.
It's not CGI.
- But it was scary.
- Would you ever do this?
- No way.
Let's make that clear, many
of the things that you do
on video, I would never do.
- What would happen if
I got my arm bitten off?
- Well, you have to call EMS,
then call the lawyer later.
- Yeah.
For sure.
- This is the Try Guys Fertility Test.
- AKA the sperm jack off race.
- [Keith] Do you ever think
the things we do in videos
are embarrassments to our family?
- I don't think of it in
family terms, I guess.
- I'm just embarrassing myself.
- You're on your own on this one.
- Zach took about 40 minutes.
- Well, he wanted to make
sure it was done well.
- He kept missing the cup.
He'd do this and he missed.
- Ahh, he was too excite.
- Do you have any questions for me?
- We better leave that one alone.
- This is Try Guys Try Stripping.
- This would be fun.
- Wow, nice butt.
- [Keith] Yeah, that's your
future daughter-in-law,
with Zach dancing on her.
She had a great time.
- You were probably trying to get Keith
back for something that week.
- What is that?
- It's his body hair.
- Oh, lots of hair, Zach.
- [Ned's Dad] I'm proud of you, Ned.
- Thanks, dad.
- Good job.
- I don't know if you're
being serious or not.
Ariel looks like she's having
the time of her life there.
- Who can blame her?
- I mean, looks fun.
- Do you think that was inappropriate?
- Looks good to me.
- [Ned] Do you think you
would let Eugene dance on mom?
- Absolutely not.
- You're a good dancer, Eugene.
- Thank you.
Should I switch jobs now?
- You may if you lose a job.
- [Keith] Of all the strippers,
who did you think was the best?
- [Keith's Dad] Each one was unique.
- [Keith] One was better than the others.
- I guess in one of those categories,
I don't normally try to evaluate.
- [Keith] Everyone's dad
said their son was the best,
and my dad refused.
- So that was all the video clips.
- Thanks for coming and doing
all these videos with us.
- Sure.
- And watching all these videos.
I'm sure that wasn't easy for you.
- No, it wasn't.
- What do you think of our stuff?
- I think it's great.
- You're not fazed at all?
- No, I love them.
I love laughing, I love
getting to know you guys.
You know, I feel like the
guys are part of my life.
- So you're not embarrassed at all?
- No, no I did a more
number of things in my life.
I'm still alive.
(intense opera music)
Thank you for watching Try Guys.
Thank you for having me.
It was fun time, Eugene.
- [Eugene] You want me to
buy you a new shirt, right?
- Right, right.